- So, how you doing?
- [Mark] I'm great.
(Stephanie giggles)
- Excellent.
I'm not going to lie, I'd
really like to have a shower.
That would be amazing.
- [Mark] Does living on the
street make you a little-
- It makes me very insecure.
Because when I'm dirty
I'm clockable,
meaning people will take
advantage of the opportunity
to tell you what's
wrong with you out here.
And they'll laugh at you.
I had two old gentlemen sitting
on the corner this morning
and one tells the other, "Oh,
your not that old are you?"
And the other one says, and then he says,
"'Cause you know the difference
between real and fake."
And I was like, "You know what, fuck you."
You know what I mean, 'cause
that really does hurt.
And it makes me feel
a certain kind of way.
And it makes me not be able
to look people in their face.
And it makes me feel small and insecure.
And I don't appreciate
it and I deserve better.
I didn't ask for this when I got here,
it just fucking happened.
- [Mark] So, Stephanie,
where you from originally?
You didn't grow up here, in San Francisco?
- No, I'm from Dallas, Fort Worth.
- [Mark] Your from Dallas.
(car honks)
And how long you been
here in San Francisco?
- Since September 2018.
- [Mark] So, your fairly new here?
- Yeah, fairly new.
- [Mark] How was your childhood?
You had both your parents as a kid?
- Yeah.
My mom sold for Avon and my
dad worked for Six Flags.
And the didn't do drugs.
They didn't drink alcohol.
They
fought a lot, my dad was a cheater.
And I started running away from home
and then they just kicked me out one day.
And I've been on my own for 23 years.
- [Mark] Your parents
kicked you out at what age?
- Like, 18.
I've been on my own for 23 years.
- [Mark] Have you been
transgendered since-
Since what age?
- I've been trying, but
it wasn't always easy.
My family wasn't accepting
of things like that.
My neighborhood
definitely would not have put
up with something like that.
And
I kinda came out here two years ago
because, you know, my parents
disowned me and everything.
And I figured here's
my golden opportunity,
you know, to make something of myself
and to transition.
And it hasn't really worked
out the way I wanted it to.
- [Mark] What hasn't gone right?
- It's a struggle.
You know, I live on the streets,
people harass me constantly.
They belittle me, I've been hospitalized.
This guy blacked both my
eyes and broke my nose,
put me in the hospital for
like four fucking days.
I had my fucking bruises
for like, forever.
And I was so unhappy,
I felt so insecure and small.
And like,
it just like,
there's no honor,
no matter what side of
the divide that your on.
Those that have it and those that don't.
People seem to be selfish
and all about themselves.
And they don't care if you'll
freeze to death at night
as long as they can have a blanket,
they'll steal yours
And it doesn't' bother them,
and they don't lose a
second of sleep over it.
And a few times I've
almost left this place,
but there is no where else to go.
- [Mark] Where do you sleep at night?
- In a friend's car.
It wasn't always like that, but-
He's this rich gay guy,
part of the Macy family,
he's a Doublemint twin,
very Jewish about his money.
But, he let's me sleep in his car,
so, I guess he's not so bad, you know?
- [Mark] Do you use drugs down here?
- No more than anybody else,
but what you going to do?
- [Mark] And what do you do for money?
- Shill them on the streets.
You got to do something.
I mean.
I mean,
if it weren't for drugs,
I
prolly gone postal
or fucking jumped off a cliff
or fell in a crack in the ground
or jumped off a cliff, man.
It's crazy out there.
- [Mark] Have you been
transgendered since what age,
roughly?
- My parents didn't put up with that.
They didn't let me do it, I
never got to do it as a child.
I never really had a childhood.
My parents were like over
obsessive about their punishments.
They would ground me
for five years straight,
you know, which I've
done five years straight
grounded in my room.
(Stephanie scoffs)
With nothing more than a
bookshelf, no electronics,
no TV.
There's TV shows that I know that existed,
but I've never seen them,
I only can identify them by the sound
of the beginning credits and music.
Because I would listen to
it from underneath the door.
I was always locked in my room,
I never got to have friends.
When friends came to my house,
they were turned away by my parents.
They made me eat my dinner for breakfast,
before I could have my breakfast,
if I didn't finish my dinner.
You know what I mean, I
was itching to get away.
And now I'm just itching
to go back indoors.
I hate it.
- [Mark] What's been the
roughest period of you life?
- Huh?
- [Mark] What's been the
roughest time of your life?
- Now.
- [Mark] And your transition is-
Are you doing surgeries
as well as hormones?
- Not yet.
- But your taking hormones?
- They're not going to get me surgeries.
I living on the fucking streets.
- [Mark] Do you have friends?
Stephanie?
- No.
(Stephanie mumbles)
My friends are able to screw me over.
I don't have any friends.
There's people that would
call me their friend,
but they're not my friend.
You know?
Everybody wants something out here,
they all have ulterior motive to take us.
Sometimes I don't understand it.
You know what I mean,
there can't be one thing genuine out here,
it's all ulterior motive.
There's always something
behind every fucking thing.
You know what I mean?
And sometimes I just
can't put my finger on it.
What the fuck is the
ulterior motive in this but,
you know, there is, it's ridiculous.
It could be sex or, you know,
it's rough.
This is probably the roughest
time in my entire life,
yes.
I feel like I'm still good looking,
but because I'm dirty
and I'm on the street,
I feel like no man wants me,
that I can't get one.
I sometimes feel like I'm
stuck out here forever.
(Stephanie sighs)
- [Mark] What's been the
best time of your life?
- Prolly the first six months I was here.
Probably the first six months I was here.
I was in Bayview for like six
months to a year, or whatever
I hooked up with this non binary,
he was a sweetheart.
But he was polyamorous and I got jealous,
because I didn't understand it.
He left me
and he fucking
just left,
and I've kind of been
stuck out here since.
You know, sometimes I
get suicidal out here.
And when your alone and
you don't have anybody,
you know, it gives you
plenty of time to think
about how you would do it.
And don't get me wrong, I know
exactly how I would do it.
But I'm thankful everyday that I don't.
You know, I'm smart enough
not to go into places
and tell them that I'm
suicidal and, you know,
I'm smart enough and I was
raised better than that,
than to take the easy way out.
You know, but, you know, I
hope that this was just out
and touches someones heart or if that it
changes people way of thinking.
'Cause when people are mean and divided
and selfish
and prejudiced and they harass you,
they don't know what your going through,
they don't know you.
And sometimes I feel
like it would be better
if they just walked up to you and said,
"Hey, what's the matter,
what can I do for you,"
instead of always about me.
Everything's always
about me out here, man.
Say, why don't people
just stop for a second
and ask you what's wrong.
What's wrong with you?
Is there something I could do for you?
That would probably make San
Francisco a much better place.
- [Mark] You feel being transgender
was something you were born with?
- Yeah, absolutely.
- [Mark] Yeah.
- I wouldn't take it back for anything.
It's who I am.
There's nothing I want
more in my entire life.
I just don't know if I'm going
to be able to achieve it.
Because they're not going to
let me get all the services
out here on the street,
you know?
So.
Izzy, my friend was telling me today,
that our friend Jasmine was murdered and
stabbed countless times
and found below the Civic
Center or something,
hotel or some shit.
And like, I was like, I told
him, "I don't want to die."
You know?
You never know who's going
to pick you up out there man.
You know, I always, when I'm angry,
I always say things like,
"Just my luck, a serial killer
will pick me up this evening
and I wouldn't be here on Monday,"
but I'm only kidding.
I mean, that shit is
fucking scary as fuck.
You know what I mean?
'Cause there's a lot of
fucking crazy people out here,
really fucking crazy.
You know, I'm not one
of them, I'm not crazy.
I like to believe that I'm
level headed, you know.
- [Mark] Have you had a
lot of bad experiences?
- I've been beat up twice out here.
You know, one by Clyde Security
and one night, just trying
to go to the bathroom
and he followed me outside.
And I was just teasing him, I said,
"Well if you don't let me go inside
I guess I'm going to
have to go right here."
And he said, "If you do-"
and said something about punching me.
And I was like-
I acted like I was pulling pants down,
but I didn't.
And he socked me in the nose,
made me shit myself right
in front of the building.
He was the only one working that night
and I should have fucking sued
when they told me to, and-
(Stephanie sniffs)
And then that same week,
this guy in the Tenderloin
I was-
I'm a little bit of a smart ass sometimes,
but everybody's knows I'm kidding.
Somebody punched me behind there,
I think, and I was like,
"Why? Because you
brought your trick over?"
And he fucking just like,
went punching the shit out of me man,
with three incisions on my face.
And somehow I just opened hands
and he punched me square
in the nose, broke it,
blacked both my eyes and
had me depressed for like
next two weeks, I was
just so fucking depressed,
'cause it was like-
He had rings on all of
fingers, all skull rings.
And
he had spike on one,
and the spike punctured
me at the top of my nose,
which is right here, and
put me in the hospital.
They were going to keep me longer,
but I chose to get up and go.
So, it's rough out here man, you know?
And a lot of the cultures,
they don't understand transgender,
they harass you when you
walk down the street.
Not everybody is friendly.
In the most homosexual city in the world,
you'd be surprised,
but there are so many
here that are against it.
And it's not based on any race or culture
or anything like that,
it's just who certain people are
and how they were raised.
And the things that they
were brought up to believe
that were planted in they're heads
as young kids and they grew
up to believe these things
and now they can't walk
past a person like me
without making harassment.
I've been called a He-man,
because of my muscles.
(Stephanie sniffs)
- [Mark] With your family disowning you
and some of the acceptance
you just don't get
in general, as a transgendered,
you find it's a very lonely life?
- I find transgender is a lonely life.
I feel like I'm alone
period.
(Stephanie sighs)
(Stephanie sniffs)
- [Mark] What would you hope
to see happen in your future,
do you have dreams of anything?
- Of course I have
dreams like anybody else.
(Stephanie audibly breathes)
(bracelets clink)
Right now I just want to
get on my fucking feet.
I get so fucking tired sometimes.
Sometimes it's just mentally exhausting.
I just want to get on my
fucking feet right now.
I just want to get on my feet for now.
(Stephanie sniffs)
You know, I don't have the
dreams I had a long time ago.
I don't really know what
my dreams are anymore.
I just want to get on my feet
and go get my surgeries and
(Stephanie sniffs)
change my fucking appearance,
fall off the edge of the planet
and start a new life.
- [Mark] All right Stephanie.
Well, thank you for talking with me.
- For sure. That's it?
- [Mark] That's it.
Is there anything else
you'd like to share?
(Stephanie sniffs)
(lips smack)
(Mark laughs)
Your cute.
- Thank you.
- [Mark] Thank you, Stephanie.
- [Stephanie] For sure.
I hope you get to hear my voice on there.
- [Mark] Oh yeah.
- [Stephanie] Okay.
Sorry about being so emotional
it's just, it's rough.
- [Mark] That was a nice talk.
- [Stephanie] Aw, thank you.
- [Mark] It's nice, you were so open.
(Stephanie sniffs)
- [Stephanie] For sure.